We're talking about...
Ja, FIFA und das Thema Doping, das soll uns auch rund im Kontext dieser Weltmeisterschaft 2018 in Russland beschäftigen und damit hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Hacob-Oss, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und Moderator dieser kleinen Sendung, in der wir mal so alle Aspekte ein bisschen aufarbeiten wollen, die rund um Doping mit der WM interessant sind und dann eben auch einige Fragen stellen, nämlich kann man davon ausgehen, dass eventuell doch gedoppt wird oder sind das alles nur Mutmaßungen. Dazu habe ich zwei sehr, sehr, sehr kompetente Menschen hier bei mir versammelt in der Runde und ich bin sehr froh, dass ich Grit Hartmann hier begrüßen darf. Sie recherchiert im Bereich des IOC schon länger, auch über Doping und im Grunde eigentlich über so fast alle Themen, die die großen Sportverbände gerne unter dem Teppich lassen würden, unter denen sie sie selbst gekehrt haben. Sie heißt atgrit-hartmann bei Twitter, hat skandalöserweise noch keinen eigenen Wikipedia-Eintrag, aber sie ist hier im Rasenfunk. Hallo Grit, schön, dass du mal mit dabei bist. Und außerdem schon eine bekannte Stimme aus schon einigen Sendungen zum Thema Fußball-Doping. Jonathan Sachse vom Correctiv, dem investigativen Recherchenetzwerk. Er schreibt unter anderem auf Fußball-Doping.de seit Jahren konsequent über das Thema und war auch schon mehrfach hier im Rasenfunk. Servus Jonathan. Freut mich sehr, dass wir diese illustre Runde haben. Bevor wir loslegen, danke ich noch ganz herzlich. Stefan.exe, Nina, Maximilian, Emanuel, Gustav und Ed Manuon, sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporter. Das heißt, sie unterstützen, dass der Rasenfunk weiter werbefrei und sponsorenfrei bleiben kann. Und in dem Sinne seid auch ihr Unterstützer, denn ihr bekommt leider noch kein Herr Honorar für eure Zeit hier und habt euch trotzdem auf diese Sendung vorbereitet. Deswegen vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank schon mal für eure Teilnahme. Wer uns unterstützen möchte, kann das tun auf rasenfunk.de/.unterstützen. Aber jetzt wollen wir mal zum Thema kommen. Grit, warum lohnt sich denn im Bereich Fußball und Doping ein Blick auf den Fußball besonders?
Gut, aber das eine ist ja jetzt quasi dann die journalistische Arbeit vor Ort. Das andere ist die aktuell stattfindende Berichterstattung. Und da finde ich, ist man schon beim Thema Doping im Fußball ein bisschen in einem Dilemma. Also ich schaffe es hier im Rasenfunk immer wieder, das Thema stattfinden zu lassen. Aber auch in der Sendung zum Beispiel meandern wir eigentlich um die WM so ein bisschen herum. Wir haben es jetzt hoffentlich ganz gut aufgearbeitet, was da interessant zu wissen ist für die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Aber man hat ein bisschen ein Henne-Eye-Problem. Dadurch, dass es eine solche Blackbox ist und dass man gerade keine aktuellen neuen Erkenntnisse hat – vielleicht reden wir gleich noch ganz kurz über das, was Howard Sapplet aufgedeckt hat rund um die WM – aber darüber hinaus gibt es so arg viel weniges – kann man dann eher immer so das machen, was wir jetzt auch gemacht haben. Hinweisen auf, da hat ein russischer Spieler direkt vor seiner Einwechslung an etwas geschnüffelt. Da gab es ein Stichlöcher und die Antwort, das haben wir, um seine Leistungswerte zu bestimmen, abgezogen. Da kann man hinterfragen, muss man das wirklich an der Vene machen oder macht man das nicht häufiger am Ohrläppchen? Könnte man Mediziner zu befragen? Aber es gibt ja sehr, sehr wenig Konkretes, über das man berichten könnte. Außer dessen – und das hätte ich mir auch wirklich gewünscht, auch in der Berichterstattung vor allem der Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, die eben einfach die größte Reichweite im Fernsehen haben – dass man mal beschreibt, wie ist eigentlich das Doping-System im Fußball, also das Anti-Doping-System aufgebaut. Das, was wir jetzt im ersten Teil dieser Sendung gemacht haben, weil ich glaube, da gibt es auch noch große Wissenslücken bei den Fußballkonsumentinnen und Konsumenten. Vielleicht ist es ihnen auch egal, aber zumindest sollte man es ihnen schon mal erzählen. Du übrigens, hier läuft das nach komplett anderen Regeln, nach den eigenen Regeln des Fußballs, als in vielen anderen Sportarten. Aber ansonsten hat man ja wirklich dieses Problem, worüber soll man sprechen? Und wenn man das Thema immer wieder nur mit so einer moralischen Keule bringt, dann setzen da ja auch Ermüdungserscheinungen ein bei den Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörern.
Es ist schon richtig, Max, aber Jonathan hat ja angefangen, ein paar Themenvorschläge sozusagen zu machen, die aber nicht stattfinden während dieser WM. Also es gibt noch eine ganz andere Beitrag über die Mannschaftsärzte, die dort beim Fußball unterwegs sind. Also zum Beispiel der Mannschaftsarzt der Engländer war schon in Doping-Ermittlungen verwickelt. Ja, habe ich in Deutschsprachigkeit einen Beitrag drüber gelesen, englischsprachig einen, glaube ich. Also es gibt dort wirklich viele Zugänge. Man muss es nur wollen. Und das passiert nicht. Du kannst natürlich nicht – wir können leider bei einer WM keine Doping- Fälle aufdecken. Das liegt nicht in unserer Macht. Also wir wissen nicht, was bei den Tests rauskommt. Das ist die Blackbox. Und wir wissen auch nicht, ob Doping-Fälle verschleiert werden oder sonst was. Die Strukturen kannst du darstellen, wie du richtig sagst. Aber ich bin der festen Aufüberzeugung, es gibt auch dort viele Möglichkeiten. Sie werden aber nicht wahrgenommen. Und das liegt natürlich zum Teil daran, dass es sich um – wenn du Fernsehen ansprichst – um Rechteverwerter handelt. Aber da würde ich mich jetzt ein bisschen wehren wollen. Also nicht nur, weil ich für die ARD arbeite, aber da gab es immerhin tatsächlich die Sendung von Haio dazu. Ob das nun genug ist und man während der WM dort auch vielleicht mit anderen Kollegen noch was anderes hätte machen können, darüber spreche ich jetzt mal nicht. Das ZDF hat – gab es einen sehr schönen Beitrag von Markus Ham, der mal aus einer anderen Blackbox beschaffen ist. Das waren nur vier Minuten, aber immerhin zwar da. Mir fehlt das ehrlich gesagt bei den hunderten Zeitungs- und Rundfunkjournalisten mindestens genauso wie beim Fernsehen. Da ist schlicht und einfach nicht genug Neugier da. Man will sich nicht anlegen. All das, was da mitspielt und was eigentlich nicht zu unserem Beruf gehören sollte. Ich finde auch nicht, dass wir nur spekulieren. Wir sagen ja schon ganz klar, wo die wunden Punkte sind im Fußball. Wir können auf Umfragen hinweisen, wir können auf bestimmte Leistungsparameter hinweisen. Wir können auch, da war immer noch gar nicht gesprochen, dass es noch was kannte, als die Leistungsparameter zu beobachten. Das ist auch ein Problem, wenn man sich die körperlichen Entwicklungen von Spielern anguckt, sieht man da schon was. Da gibt es Spieler, die keinen Körperfett mehr haben. Da gibt es Spieler, die vor vier Jahren völlig anders aussahen als sie jetzt. Jetzt sind sie mit Muskeln vollgepackt und das sind nicht nur Stürmer. Das ist auch sehr riskant, aber auch da kannst du etwas sehen. Das sind nicht nur Spekulationen, sondern auch die, die du machen musst und kannst, wenn du über Doping sprichst. Wenn du das kombinierst mit dem Test, dann ergibt sich ein klares Bild.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass der Zuschauer müde ist. Das ist nicht meine Erfahrung. Ich rede jetzt öfters mit Leuten über das Thema. Wenn die irgendwie hören, ich mache Fußball-Doping, kommt immer weiterhin die erste Frage, ob das überhaupt Sinn macht. Über ein Jahrzehnt gestreckt jetzt fast. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass du an irgendeiner Stelle die öffentliche Aufklärung zu dem Punkt gekommen bist, wo diese Frage nicht mehr gestellt werden muss. Auch bei Interviews ist das, wenn man irgendwo ein Radio-Interview gibt, meistens immer noch die erste Frage. Klar, Leute, die jetzt unseren Vier-Stunden-Podcast gehört haben und heute wieder zugehört haben, die werden an ein paar Stellen richtig zuhören, verstehe ich total. Aber ich glaube, in der breiten Öffentlichkeit ist das weiterhin nicht so angekommen. Also diese Basisbegründung, da würde es auch schon helfen, wenn so eine Dokumentation wie die von Hajo Seppelt gesendet wurde, nicht nachts läuft, sondern zu einer prominenteren Sendezeit. Man hat ja genug Möglichkeiten, gerade nach dem Ausscheiden von Deutschland vielleicht auch, wo man andere Themen platzieren kann. Oder auch einfach mal, es müssen auch nicht die großen Recherchen sein. Es reicht ja auch, wenn ein kritischer Geist eingeladen wird. Es gibt ja genug Interviewformate, der einfach mal zu dem Thema mit einer Viertelstunde befragt wird. Wenn dann sozusagen zwischen den drei Herren mal so hin und her moderiert wird in der ARD, dann kann ja irgendwer von den drei noch mal abgeben zum Interview mit Perricle Simon oder jemand anderem, der sich vielleicht als Gegenwart noch dazu äußern möchte.
Ja, sehr gerne auch mal eine Frau. Dann haben wir auch noch mehr Frauen in der Berichterstattung. Hätten wir hier zum Beispiel eine in der Runde gehabt, die auch dazu gestunden hätte, sicher. Ich stelle mal die Frage dir, Jonathan, weil ich weiß, dass Grit auch schon viel mit Hajo Seppett zusammengearbeitet hat. Wie wichtig ist denn dann so eine Figur wie Hajo Seppett mit seinen Dokumentationen, die jetzt im Laufe der WM rauskam und der ja auch ein bundesweites Interesse hervorgerufen hat, dadurch, dass ihm erst die Einreise nach Russland verwehrt wurde oder das Visum und er dann entschieden hat, aus Sicherheitsgründen in Deutschland zu bleiben?
Ich glaube, nicht er hat das entschieden, sondern das darf man eher als Anordnung von ARD verstehen. Sie schicken ihren Mann da nicht hin. Aber zu der Frage, klar, also an bestimmten Personen, ich glaube, so ein Narrativ, also Hajo Seppett ist ja fast ein Narrativ geworden zu dem Thema, ist schon wichtig, um sozusagen die Leute auch mal wieder daran erinnern zu können, dass das ein Thema ist. Und es ist auch wichtig, dass dadurch sozusagen die Möglichkeit entwickelt wurde, dass Hajo Seppett jetzt auch wirklich Ressourcen bekommt, um da mehr zu dem Thema machen zu können. Es ist aber auch gleichzeitig kompliziert, wenn sich das alles an einer Person oder sozusagen die Gruppe, die um Hajo Seppett existiert, und Grit Hartmann auch teilweise mal mitrecherchiert, aber dass sich das dann sozusagen zu sehr konzentriert auf diese eine Gruppe, weil dann könnte so eine Art Feigenblatt-Funktion angetreten werden, dass man immer wieder abschiebt, wir haben doch da die Truppe, die es macht, und die kann natürlich auch nicht alles machen. Also auch da sind die Ressourcen weiterhin beschränkt. Und man kann jetzt nicht einfach immer nur darauf warten, dass alle paar Monate mal ein neuer 20-Minuten-Halbstunde kommt, wo dann wieder das Thema bearbeitet wurde. Dann kann man im Jahresbericht oder in einer Pressekonferenz einmal pro Jahr sagen, wir haben das Thema ja ausführlich behandelt in den vier Dokumentationen. Das ist auch nicht ausreichend. Also dafür müssen schon mehr Leute Ressourcen bekommen. Und es muss auch alltäglicher werden. Das ist ja das, was wir gerade schon ausführlich besprochen haben. Dass eben auch ganz normale zwei- dreimalige Mütter zwischendurch entstehen, kleine Einspieler, wo genau das Thema behandelt wird. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die es in der Tour de France total gab. Das ist auch noch nicht alles okay. Aber ich war ja mal drei Jahre sozusagen bei Tour de France vor Ort und durfte das auch mal im ZDF-Produktionsteam miterleben. Das ist viel alltäglicher geworden, auch in den Redaktionsbesprechungen damals. Dass man überlegt, okay, was machen wir jetzt zum Thema Doping? Und dann gibt es einen, der macht genau so was, wie es jetzt bei WM gesagt hat. Der läuft den ganzen Tag, rennt den Fahrer nach Zielanfahrt hinterher. Braucht man vier Konditionen für und beobachtet einfach mal, was passiert, sozusagen von der Züge bis er vom Schaperau eingefangen wurde und zur Kontrolle gebracht worden und so. Das sind ja ganz normale Beiträge, die überall umsetzbar sind. Hab ich jetzt was zu deiner Frage vergessen?
Ich glaube, du hast schon die Frage, wie wichtig dann so eine Figur oder ein Narrativ, wie du es dann etabliert hast, ist, ganz gut in beide Richtungen beantwortet, glaube ich. Also ja, auf der einen Seite natürlich wichtig, aber auf der anderen Seite kann es eben auch als Feigenblatt wirten. Und der Komplex ist zu groß, eigentlich nur für ein Team aus Journalisten. Deswegen darf man sich nicht nur auf deren Arbeit verlassen und auch nicht nur deren Arbeit als Hinweis darauf nehmen, dass man sich mit Doping auseinandergesetzt hat.
Ich weise kurz darauf hin, dass es bei der ARD natürlich auch die Sendung WDR Sport in Tarpf gibt, die sehr verdienstvoll ist. Und dort gibt es nicht nur – das ist ein bisschen weiterer verandert – aber schon auch Beiträge, die sich mit Doping befassen und die nicht von H. Seppelt sind.
Aber weißt du, was mich da eilgert, Grit, bei dieser Sendung? Das ist meiner Meinung nach die beste sport-journalistische TV-Sendung, die es in Deutschland gibt. Und die kommt irgendwann unmoderiert, nicht mal mehr inzwischen von einem Moderator moderiert, am Sonntagabend. Und wenn ich dem entgegenhalte, was in der Sportschau um 18.30 im Filetstück der deutschen Sportberichterstattung gemacht wird, da ist das nur, wir gucken jetzt, ach, die Partie Hamburg gegen den 1. FC Kaiserslautern, die gab es ja schon mal 1984. Und damals ist eine Eckfahne umgefallen. Wir fragen nochmal alle Beteiligten dazu. Das ist das, was mich wirklich manchmal ärgert. Man muss ja auch nicht mit kritischer Berichterstattung den Leuten die Freude am Sport nehmen. Aber warum finden so tolle journalistische Inhalte in einer so versteckten Nische statt und werden ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz selten mal ins breitere Lampenlicht, Rampenlicht getrieben?
Also das ist natürlich eine Frage, die völlig berechtigt ist, die ich jetzt noch nicht beantworten kann. Aber das kleine Trostpflaster ist sozusagen, dass sie unmoderiert ist, finde ich übrigens gut. Ich brauche keinen Moderator. Wenn ich drei gute Beiträge mit jeweils einem Vorspann hintereinander bekomme, muss ich nicht einen haben, der dazwischen vor dem Puls steht und mir noch was erzählt. Das glaube ich nicht. Aber zumindest gibt es die Tendenz, dass es immer mehr Beiträge von Sport Inside gibt, wenn sie gut sind, wenn sie investigativ sind. Das ist dort die überwiegende Zahl der Beiträge, dass es Kurzfassungen davon zumindest in der Sportschau gibt. Das ist schon so am selben Wochenende. Das sind dann nicht zehn Minuten wie bei Sport Inside, sondern fünf Minuten.
Es ist auch nicht die 1830-Sportur. Ich weiß, dass jede Sendeminute sehr eng verplant ist, aber das ist das, wo alle hingucken.
Ja, doch ab und an gibt es das da. Ab und an auch da. Es könnte häufiger sein. Aber ich glaube, das ist eine gute Entwicklung. Und ansonsten ist das natürlich richtig mit der Nische. Da kann ich nichts anderes sagen.
Sorry, Grit, natürlich. Ich muss auch noch unterstützen. Das ist der Arsch auf mein Haupt. Das ist das einzige Format, das wöchentlich kritische Sportberichterstattung bringt. In einem regelmäßigen Format. Also klar, hätte ich natürlich benennen müssen. Wir wollen jetzt hier nicht mit so kleinen Medienkritik anfangen, aber mein Problem als Nutzer, der wenig in den Jahresfernsehen noch schaut, ist bei SportInside, die PR-Arbeit, um den eigenen Beitrag zu kriegen. Bei mir ploppt das kaum noch auf, außer ich werde daran erinnert. Ich weiß, ich hatte eine Kollegin Beitrag gemacht, den will ich unbedingt noch sehen. Und bei Twitter mal, wenn das vermarktet wird. Aber ich muss mich erst mal um Bemühen oder erinnert werden. Ach ja, stimmt, wieder SportInside-Sendung. Was ist denn da passiert? Jetzt kriege ich mich mal durch die Mediathek. Das ist ein bisschen mein Problem. SportInside-Sendung habe ich mich gerade auch vergessen.
Dazu kommt, du hast auch unregelmäßige Sendetermine. Es gibt eine sehr lange Sommerpause, wenn keine Bundesliga ist. Das macht es nicht ganz so einfach. Aber die Frage war ja, eigentlich reicht das, wenn man so eine Liedfigur hat wie Hajo bei der Doping-Berichterstattung. Wie gesagt, Fernsehen ist nicht alles. Es gibt auch ein paar andere, die nicht fürs Fernsehen arbeiten, die wir auch nicht vergessen wollen, die sich um Doping bemühen. Aber ich finde, so eine Liedfigur wie Hajo kann nur gut sein, wenn sie dazu motiviert, dass sich auch andere Kollegen häufiger mit dem Thema befassen. Ich denke, dass das der Weg sein muss. Denn Hajo kann natürlich nicht alles machen. So ein Lieblingsvorwurf von Leuten, die man nicht unbedingt ernst nehmen muss – ich sage Ihnen trotzdem mal, der war, der kümmert sich ja immer nur um Russland. Wieso kümmert er sich denn jetzt nicht um Frum? Wer aber die Abläufe kennt, der weiß selbstverständlich, dass wenn du gerade einen halben Stunden Film machst zum Fußball in Brasilien und einem Doping-Arzt dockt, das ist das, was gerade gelaufen ist, dann hast du überhaupt keine große Zeit, dich noch um einen anderen wichtigen Fall zu kümmern. Und das ist nun wieder ein Indiz dafür, dass es auch nicht gut ist, es nur an einem aufzuhängen. Ja, also das ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert, aber ich denke, das hajo schon. Und ich weiß es auch, bei seiner Firma gibt es also eine Menge neue junge Kollegen, die viele außerhalb noch gar nicht kennen, die aber bei ihm arbeiten, sehr glücklich darüber sind, dass sie das können und sozusagen hoffnungsvolle junge und kluge Kollegen sind, die da auch auf eine Schiene gebracht werden. Und das ist ganz schön, glaube ich.
Absolut. Ja, das ist eine richtige Tendenz. Wir wollen langsam zum Schluss dieser Sendung kommen. Ich habe auch schon eure Zeit etwas länger beansprucht als eigentlich vereinbart. Deswegen nur noch eine abschließende Frage an euch beide. Jonathan, du darfst mal anfangen. Ihr als Doping-Experten, glaubst du, bei dieser WM sind von den 736 Spielern gedopte Spieler mit dabei? Zu wie viel Prozent bist du davon überzeugt?
Ich bin davon überzeugt, dass Spieler bei dieser WM gedopt sind. Das traue ich mich zu sagen. Ich habe vorhin schon einmal beantwortet, wie viele das sind, in welcher Nation. Da kann ich nicht zu sagen. Da kann ich nur den Hinweisen folgen und irgendwann vielleicht kann man mal was darüber sprechen.
Genau. Bei dir ist die Überzeugung als jemand, der sich wirklich viel mit der Materie beschäftigt. Du bist dir sicher, es sind gedopte Spieler mit bei diesen Fußball-Chinien dabei?
Ich bin mir sicher bei dieser WM und ich bin auch sicher, dass in der Bundesliga gedopte Spieler dabei sind. Also bin ich mir eigentlich bei jedem großen, im professionellen Fußball sozusagen, bei jeder großen Liga und jedem großen Turnierformat sicher.
Grit, deckt sich das mit deiner Einschätzung?
Ja, also ich würde mal die Mindestwerte der Studien, die da so gemacht wurden, sind auch von der UEFA selbst im Übrigen. Das lag dann mal bei acht Prozent mit Testosteronen, Spitzenfußballer, die Umfrage in der Bundesliga bis zu 25 Prozent, in der Spanischen Liga bis zu 30 Prozent. Also ich bin ein bisschen kühner und sage, dass aber mindestens ein Drittel der Spieler, die bei dieser WM antreten – und eigentlich würde ich sogar noch höher gehen – dass die in dieser Saison mit Doping-Mitteln umgegangen sind und gedruckt haben.
Schade, dass es nicht wie bei einem Tippspiel ist.
Wir können es leider nicht, aber wirklich.
Das wäre ein etwas makaberes Tippspiel.
Spanische Liga – Umfrage. 30 Prozent geben es zu vor zwei Jahren. In Deutschland geben es 25 Prozent zu. Du hast, wenn du mit Leuten sprichst, die solche Umfragen machen, hast du immer noch einen 50-Prozent-Satz, die es nicht zugeben. Das sind Mindestwerte. Das sind Mindestwerte. Das sind nicht nur die Topspieler. Ich glaube, dass im Fußball die Duping-Prävalenz extrem hoch ist. Der Fußball schützt sich auch durch die Kontrollen, die noch sehr viele Alibi-Hafter sind, als sie in anderen Sportarten sind. Er will nicht finden, er schützt sich. Warum soll das geringer sein als in anderen Sportarten? Es ist eher höher.
Das setzt aber auch auf jeden Fall fest. Dieses Thema wird noch häufiger im Rasenfunk stattfinden. Vielleicht auch noch mal, wenn ich darf, mit euch in dieser Runde. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit. Zum einen Grit Hartmann bei Twitter. Grit, vielen Dank, dass du dein Debüt im Rasenfunk gegeben hast und dir so viel Zeit genommen hast für diese Sendung. Und außerdem ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an dich, Jonathan Sachse, at J. Sachse bei Twitter. Folgt auch at Fußball Doping. Und ihr könnt euch auch mal das Correctiv angucken, wo Jonathan inzwischen arbeitet. Jonathan, es war wie immer eine große Freude mit dir zu sprechen, obwohl das Thema ein nicht ganz so leicht verdauerliches an manchen Stellen ist. Danke dir.
Danke auch an euch.
Und auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war ein Tribünengespräch. Es wird noch ein weiteres Tribünengespräch geben, auch zu einem nicht ganz so einfachen Thema. Sagen wir mal, es wird um die FIFA gehen. Mal gucken, wann das veröffentlicht wird, vermutlich noch im Verlaufe dieser WM. Ansonsten gibt es die täglichen WM-Kurzpässe. Und ich freue mich, wenn ihr uns unterstützt, auf rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück um die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.